Another screening method, called
marker-assisted breeding, utilizes DNA
based technology to rapidly determine
which offspring have desired genes. To
better explain this, let's see an
example from Dr. Oliver Dong, a
researcher in Dr. Ronald's lab.
So in agriculture production, very
often, we like to combine good traits
from different plants. In this case, we
may have a parental plant that sets a
lot of seeds, and we have another
parent which does not set a lot of
seeds, but has a lot of branches.
Basically, we cross the two parents,
and we identify in the following
generations the progeny that has
combined good traits from both sides.
In this case, it would be a plant that
has lots of branches, and has lots of
seeds on each branch. However, there's
a challenge with this approach. Think
of a huge population of thousands of
plants. How can you determine which one
is the best one that contains the best
traits? That's why we need a better
method, called marker-assisted
breeding. Agricultural performance of
plants are usually linked to traits
that are encoded by DNA.
In this case, the dark circles
represent good genes, which will
control a good trait, whereas the open
circles represent not so good genes,
which will not give rise to a good
trait. In marker-assisted breeding,
instead of looking at the agricultural
performance directly in the offspring
population, we look at the genetic
makeup of these plants, and we choose
the individual that contains the most
dark circles, or the most good genes,
because this individual will have the
best agricultural performance. And this
method allows scientists to quickly
select the best individual in a
relatively short period of time,
compared to traditional breeding. This
is the method that Dr. David Mackill, a
rice breeder at UC Davis in the
International Rice Research Institute,
used to develop the original Sub1 rice
strain. First, a submergence tolerant
rice strain, FR13A,
was crossed with a variety of Swarna
rice. Then the hybrid was crossed back
to Swarna and selected over many
generations to clear the undesired
genetic background from FR13A.
What we're left with is a robustly
growing strain of Swarna rice that can
withstand flooding for up to two weeks.